there's a clip going around right now
of ibram kendy he's sort of the
mack daddy of anti-racism this this new
ideology that's very influenced by
critical race theory and other
radical leftist movements from the 20th
century so kennedy was speaking at a
church i put that in quotes i'm not sure
the exact nature of this church doesn't
sound very christian to me
and kindly
explained the religious underpinnings of
his ideology
liberation theology in other words jesus
was a revolutionary
and the job of the christian
is to revolutionize society
that the job of the christian is to
liberate society
from the powers on on earth that are
oppressing humanity
everybody understand that so
that's liberation theology in a nutshell
savior theology
is a different type of theology the job
of the christian
is to go out
and save
these individuals
who are behaviorally deficient
in other words we're to bring them into
the church these individuals
who
are doing all of these evil sinful
things and heal them
and save them
and then once we've saved them we've
done our jobs
and and to me anti-racists
fundamentally reject
savior theology
this is a very telling clip this is a
very important clip for understanding
the anti-racist movement
so from the beginning you can tell that
ibram kendy though he seems to be
talking about christianity is not you
can tell this from the very first
sentence when abram kennedy says
jesus was a revolutionary as a general
rule if
someone is referring to jesus
exclusively in the past tense
there's a very good chance you're not
dealing with a christian
because christians believe that christ
was crucified he died and rose again
from the dead and the lives my redeemer
lives this is something
we say very often this is central to our
understanding of the world
if you do not i mean christ himself says
this before abraham was i am that he is
essen the being himself
right i am i am that i am is what god
says his name is when he's speaking to
moses
so from the very beginning we can see
ibrahim kennedy whatever he's talking
about it's not really christianity but
this difference between liberation and
savior theology and his words this is
the difference between christianity and
this radical sort of leftism i've got
some pretty valuable stuff in my home
i'm not talking about furniture or
i don't know jewelry or i actually don't
have a lot of valuable stuff with regard
to that
i do have valuable
wife and baby okay and i want to make
sure that they are safe
i love ring alarm i love it
if i am in my home if i am in the office
if i am on a beach on the other side of
the world if i'm on the road i do have
to travel a fair bit for work i can be
totally safe and secure that my wife and
my cute little baby will know who is
outside the door before they open that
door and anyone actually can keep an eye
on any any inch
of their house inside outside with ring
alarm it's super easy you can control it
from your phone protect your home
anytime
from anywhere with ring alarm so simple
to install even i can do it i'm not the
handiest guy in the world okay it'll
just give you peace of mind and the
price is extraordinarily low go to
ring.com knowles for a special offer on
a ring alarm security kit today
build a system that is right for your
home have it up and running in minutes
ring.com knowles that is ring.com slash
knowles ibram kendy who is presently the
head honcho of anti-racism the capo de
tutti copy of race hustlers ibrahim
kendy
is
has this viral video that was going
around of him speaking in some sort of
church or some sort of building
and congregation that referred to itself
as a church about liberation theology
and he says liberation theology holds
that the purpose of christianity and of
the christian in the world is to
liberate everybody from the bonds of
oppression and tradition and whatever
else
he says this
contrasts with savior theology which
holds that the the role of the christian
in the world is to go evangelize and
spread the gospel and bring people into
the body of christ so what ibrahim
kennedy is derisively referring to as
savior theology is also just known as
christianity that christianity which is
the point is to spread the good news
just as the apostles did just as
uh the disciples of jesus did go out and
spread the good news of the gospel bring
people into the body of christ and save
them ibrahim kennedy says this is very
bad we cannot go out and save people if
you go out there and you say people are
doing bad things and they need to stop
doing bad things and start doing good
things and accept jesus
and and come into the church and that's
very bad that's oppressive
that that reeks of white supremacy or
whatever
so we can't have any of that instead we
need to liberate people
and that the key here is this word
liberation
because to my mind to my mind as a
catholic as a christian
in the broadest sense
the two are the same thing the two are
the same thing
when you
come to faith
when you accept
jesus when you accept
theological religious truth
you are freed you are freed from the
bonds of sin
and what does it mean to be freed of the
bonds of sin well you see it in the
gospels jesus says the man who sins is a
slave to sin
take the religious stuff
away for a moment just focus in this
very practical tangible way we all know
that when we sin when we pick up bad
habits
we become slaves to those sins we call
this addiction
when you do too many drugs all of a
sudden you can't control whether or not
you do the drugs your your lower will
runs away with you your appetite runs
away with you you can't do it this is
true even with food if you if you
overeat you can't put down that cupcake
you can't say no you don't have
self-control the point of liberal
education which we mention on the show a
lot is to make sense of your freedom
tamp down those base appetites cultivate
the higher rational will which mediates
between the appetite and the divine will
okay that's the that's the two second
summary of what we mean by this
what
ibram kendi believes is that true
liberation is being able to do whatever
you want
i think it even goes further true
liberation is the freedom to commit vice
and sin and to pursue your appetites and
that is
slavery that is
that is a christianity without a without
christ that is christianity without god
because you you can do it all yourself
as long as as long as we the liber the
liberators come in
and we free you from the bonds of
tradition as long as the anti-racists go
in and free you from the bonds of
whatever oppressive social structures
there are then you can be free to do
whatever you want and you don't need god
and you don't need christ and you don't
need grace and you don't need a religion
it is
a god without wrath leading a people
without sin into a kingdom without
judgment through the ministrations of a
christ without a cross
so that you can do you and do whatever
you want it's the opposite of
christianity but it adopts the language
of christianity
and this
it's important to know where this
ideology comes from because it's
pervading all the military now the
schools the our workplaces
but it comes down to that same old
problem that we've been talking about
the problem what do we mean by liberty
is liberty just the ability to do
whatever you want or is it the right to
do what you ought to do i'm so glad you
liked that clip stop what you're doing
ring the bell subscribe that way you'll
get notifications for the whole episode
of this podcast also if you want to
avoid the
big tech censorship that has been pretty
crazy lately head on over to apple
podcast but if i stitch your google play
wherever you get your podcasts subscribe
to the michael knowles show that is
t-h-e m-i-c-h-a-e-l-w-l-e-s-s-h-o-w
click subscribe leave a five-star review
appreciate it see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you